the corona virus pandemic has created a
new way of life that has so far been
unfamiliar in any of our lifetimes an
analysis conducted by King's College
suggests there are three types of people
in lockdown those who accept those who
suffer and those who resist so what else
are the psychologists discovering during
covert 19 while joining me now is
sassani Wesley who's chair of
psychological medicine at King's College
London and how are we all coping
mentally well I think it's you know the
report that we just published yesterday
shows that um it's a varied picture now
from being fairly uniform start it seems
to be fragmenting more which is what
you'd expect and as you've said there's
a large group the largest group of
people are pretty much getting on with
it these tend to be older they're not
particularly anxious or depressed
they're cooperating a lot up to 90% with
the restrictions and we'd call them
pretty much accepting they're not always
happy about it but that's still not
particularly disturbed equally large of
the group of people who definitely are
suffering you have very high rates of
anxiety and depressive symptoms who are
much more fearful about the future who
tend to be a bit younger and also tend
tend to be more female but who are
complying almost a hundred percent with
the restrictions and some of them feel
they should go further and then you've
got 10 percent or not who really are not
happy at all about the situation they
are not complying less than 50 percent
they feel the lockdown has already gone
on to the model and so on so it's
fragmenting as you would imagine it
would as the time progresses so did I
dread in the last couple of weeks that
those people who are naturally quite
anxious he may have suffered an anxiety
or made myself with depression in the
past are actually finding lock down a
little bit easier than others who aren't
is it is that what your research has
shown no I wasn't aware of that
particular work I mean there's huge
amounts of work going on it's quite
difficult to keep in touch with it in
general in the mental how we are seeing
is less people attending for example in
A&E with anxiety depression or overdoses
considerably less but that's not a good
marker because that just says that a any
attendances are down dramatically anyway
and Mental Health Services are reporting
particularly the more severely mentally
ill a whole range of reaction so I
haven't seen that particular issue
it would be somewhat surprising I have
to say because so much of what we have
to do now the constant checking the
constant washing they're being asked to
monitor our symptoms etc are not really
calculated to ease those who are nervous
or tense or worried about their health
anyway why do you think women are more
likely to be at the anxious and
depressed in the lockdown I think that's
because we have high rates of depression
anxiety in in in in females anyway
so I think it's an exception of that on
the other hand we have lower rates of
drink and in there is in the those who
really are actively resisting Djem more
male and younger you also have quite
considerable increase in alcohol so I
think different genders that there is a
gender differentiation and how we
respond to pressure and stress and this
has been accentuated it hasn't been
created by the pandemic but it's been
clearly accentuated when when we talk
about this pandemic what we mustn't
forget is that the dead the large number
of people who are passing away and their
restrictions over funerals how is that
affecting people's mental health it is
of course dreadful to lose anyone you
love but to lose someone you love in
these circumstances how much harder does
it make it I think I mean I think that's
a rather obvious question I think most
people know the answer I'm not aware of
any research on that but I'm not sure we
need to do research you know it's really
bad breaking the rituals of mourning and
funerals particularly if you're unable
to see your your relative in their last
days or hours clearly creates a much
more complicated intense and difficult
grieving process but we we know from
before the pandemic would be more
prolonged tide it's not an area I would
tend to do research on because it's what
everybody knows anyway and it's awful
and the sooner that we can end that for
all people sake the better both reducing
the cost of lives but also and some
hospitals actually making really quite
impressive efforts using different
technologies to try and ease that but
finally until we can grieve properly
this will continue to be a burden so in
short how how can we best arm ourselves
mentally for what's going to come in the
next few weeks I think I think the issue
of the other issue that survey picked up
which is a concern is an email for all
the restrictions were lifted tomorrow
which obviously isn't ready to happen
but if it did it isn't that people then
flood out into the streets into the
parks into the bars and the restaurants
and football ground remarkably high
rates of up to 60% for example saying
they would not resume public transport
40% say they would not send their
children back to school or would not go
to pubs clubs and restaurants now that
doesn't mean that they won't when it
does happen but it suggests that it's
not going to be anything like as simple
as we think and we know that after
previous disasters has taken a very long
time possibly never for certain things
to us resume how we were and it also
means the guns got to make some choices
here do you when it is safe to do those
things do you then still continue to
insist on social distancing etc etc in
order to reassure people or do
alternately say well it's up to you now
if you want to go to these places you
now can it is now safe but it's your
choice but we will lift the restrictions
I think that's finally going to be a
political decision it's not for doctors
not ferb boring boffins like me it's
really about the politicians how much do
they trust the public but also how much
do they feel they can must continue to
keep restrictions in place to allow
fears now as opposed to a realistic
chances of danger and that's going to be
a difficult question I think but it's
going to have to be addressed
okay so silently we leave it there thank
you very much